JEREMY WALKER: Hi, my
name's Jeremy Walker.
We're continuing
our talk on GEEs.
Those are Google
Developer experts
who help us out with the APIs.
Again, we have three that
came out for YouTube.
And today we're actually
to talk with someone
from all the way south,
from Argentina, Matias,
and he's going to tell us
a little bit about what
he's been up to.
Enjoy the show.
And we're continuing
our conversation
with our global YouTube
developer experts.
So next, we have
our veteran, Matias.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Hi,
I am from Argentina.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, he
covers South America.
He's all over the place down
there, thankfully, for us.
And we were talking a little
bit about the Android Player
API, which for you
that don't know,
it's an API that allows you to
play YouTube within your app.
But before I jumped
into that, I wanted
to talk about something
that's a little related.
You did a PhoneGap
Code Lab, and so I
wanted you to talk a little bit
about that and your experience.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Yes, I tried
to use the YouTube Multiplayer
inside a PhoneGap app because
PhoneGap is a good framework
to make a proof of concepts,
your first app in a hack-a-thon
because you can
do that very fast.
In my first test, I
used the iFrame player,
but I believe that
maybe the Multiplayer
is better for an Android app.
And I tried to use
Android Multiplayer using,
actually building,
a PhoneGap line.
And I realized that
it's too much better.
The experience using
the Multiplayer
is better than
the iFrame player.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, so you
developed the phone app after--
MATIAS MOLINAS: The year after.
JEREMY WALKER: -Code
Lab-- which, by the way,
is really great.
But you found that you had to
use the WebView so you can make
a really quick
hack-a-thon type deal.
So the Android Player API,
you didn't actually use there,
but you were saying
that for the comparison
when you actually built
outside a phone app,
with the Android Player
versus the WebView,
you found it a little bit easier
to use the Android Player API.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Yes, I found
that it's-- in my [INAUDIBLE],
I used the iFrame player,
because I made all the app with
Javascript.
I used that API to
get recommendations.
But I believe that the Android
Player is the best experience,
so I tried it.
I realized that it is better.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, you know
the phone app thing was great.
It's a great way to get
people started in Android
and maybe they aren't as
experienced with Android
development.
So I guess when you were
using the Android Player API,
did you have any feature
requests that you would like?
MATIAS MOLINAS: Yes, because
it is a mobile scenario.
I believe that maybe more
buffering or maybe offline--
if you can manage the
video to play something
in an offline scenario,
it could be great.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
So buffering is something we're
always improving and optimizing
on from that Player API.
And then we've heard a lot of
feature requests for offline,
so we know that's a big
one from the audience.
Matias, again,
thanks for running
around all of South America
and promoting the YouTube APIs.
And thanks to the
audience for joining us.
And look for, if you're
in South America,
look to see Matias talking
about the YouTube APIs.
Thanks.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Thanks.